The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LORNA GIBSON: So
we're going to start
talking about trabecular
bone, and we're
going to do a bone
today and on Wednesday.
And I'm hoping we can more or
less finish it on Wednesday.
So hello.
Hold on a sec.
So these are some images
of trabecular bone,
and you can see that it
has a foam-like structure.
And trabecular bone exists in
certain places in the body.
There's three main
places that it exists.
So it exists at the
end of the long bones.
And over here this is a femur.
This is the very
top of the femur,
and you can see this is all
trabecular bone in here.
This is a tibia, and this is
the top of your knee there.
And you can see how the bone
get more bulbous at the ends,
and it's filled with
a trabecular bone.
This is a vertebrae.
So vertebrae are actually
mostly trabecular bone,
and they have a
really thin shell
of what's called cortical bone,
the dense bone, on top of it.
So trabecular bone exists at
the ends of the long bones,
it exists in the core
of the vertebrae,
and it also exists in sort
of shell or plate-like bones.
So in your skull,
for example, there's
a layer of trabecular
bone in between two layers
of the compact dense bone.
And in your pelvis,
it's the same thing.
So those of you who
took 3032, you remember
when I passed around
the bird skulls, there
was that very porous
kind of trabecular bone.
So trabecular bone is
of interest medically
in three main kind of
medical situations.
So the first one
is osteoporosis.
So I want to talk a little
bit about osteoporosis now,
and then we'll talk about
it in more detail later on.
I guess, we'll
probably start today.
Another medical issue
is osteoarthritis,
and the properties of
the trabecular bone
are important in arthritis,
and the third issue
is in joint replacements.
And so we're going to talk a
little bit about osteoporosis,
osteoarthritis, and
then joint replacements.
And then I'll talk
a little bit more
about modeling bone like
a foam and how it deforms
and how it fails.
And then we'll talk a little bit
how we can model osteoporosis.
So let me write down
some of these things.
I guess we'll start here.
So trabecular bone has
a foam-like structure,
and what we're going
to see is that we
can use the models
for foams to describe
the mechanical
behavior of the bone.
It exists at the ends
of the long bones.
And at the ends
of the long bones,
the bones become more bulbous.
And really what that's for
is to increase the surface
area so that there's cartilage
between the ends of the two
bones.
So there would be a bone
here and a bone there,
and there's cartilage
in between them
that sort of
lubricates that joint
and makes low
friction at the joint.
And the bone gets larger
to decrease the stresses
on the cartilage.
So if you have the same force
and you have a larger area,
you're going to have
a smaller stress.
So that's why the bone
gets bulbous like that.
And then by having the
trabecular bone, because it's
so porous and
lightweight, you're
not having a big,
dense hunk of bone
at the end of the long bones.
So it exists at the
ends of the long bones.
And I'll just say the ends have
a larger area than the shafts.
And that's to distribute
the loads on the cartilage
or to reduce the stress
on the cartilage.
And then the trabecular
bone reduces the weight.
So it also exists in the
core of the vertebrae,
and in fact, it makes
up most of the vertebrae
and then in things like the
skull and the pelvic bones
in shell and plate-like bones.
And so it's the core of a
sandwich structure there.
So it's of interest
in osteoporosis,
in osteoarthritis, and
in joint replacements.
So if we start by thinking
about osteoporosis,
you probably know
that osteoporosis
is a disease where the
bone mass becomes reduced
and there's a greater
risk of fracture,
so there's especially a
greater risk of hip fractures
and vertebral fractures.
And it turns out in
both of those sites,
if you just look at
these bones here,
typically if you have a hip
fracture, what happens is
the neck of the femur breaks.
So this is called the neck here.
This is called the head,
this spherical bit there.
So the neck has a
fracture, and you
can see most of the bone
there is trabecular bone,
so it's really carrying most
of the load and the same
with the vertebrae.
This sort of cylindrical
part of the vertebrae
here carries most of the load.
It has a shell of really
thin cortical bone,
but it's mostly trabecular bone.
And when the loads are
vertical like this,
that's really the
trabecular bone that's
carrying most of the load.
And people get sometimes what
are called wedge fractures
where instead of having a sort
of a cylinder with parallel
faces like this, the
trabecular bone fails,
and the bone ends up like that
so that there's-- yeah, I know.
You make that
wincing expression.
It's like ouchy.
And in fact, it's very ouchy
for people who get that.
And when you see little
old ladies who are all
hunched over, that's why.
The bone has actually failed.
It's actually been crushed
into these wedge fractures,
and there's no way they
can straighten it out,
and it's quite painful.
So people who look
at osteoporosis
are quite interested in
the mechanical properties
of trabecular bone for
this sort of reason.
The hip fractures
are particularly
serious because people become
immobilized and then sometimes
because they're immobilized,
they get pneumonia,
and in elderly people
they sometimes die.
So something like 40% of
elderly patients who are over 65
die within a year of
having hip fracture.
So it's not that the
hip fracture kills them,
it's that they become so
immobile, and they can't move,
and they can't walk around, and
they end up getting pneumonia.
So it's quite a serious thing.
And there's something like
300,000 hip fractures a year
in the US, and the cost of
treating these hip fractures
is something like $19 billion.
So yeah, it's a huge problem.
And as the population is
aging, as baby boomers like
me get older and older,
there's going more people
having hip fractures.
So it's a huge
deal, osteoporosis.
So we'll say bone mass
decreases with age,
and osteoporosis is
extreme bone loss.
And a little later
today I'll show you
some pictures of what
it looks like when
people have osteoporosis.
So the most common fractures are
of the hip and the vertebrae,
and at both sites,
most of the load
is carried by the
trabecular bone.
And the hip fractures
you are the most serious.
40% of elderly patients
pass away within a year.
So that's sort of a little
introduction to osteoporosis.
The next issue that
people are interested in
is osteoarthritis.
And in osteoarthritis,
there's a degradation
of cartilage at the joints,
and the stress on the cartilage
is affected by the
modulus of the bone that
presses against the cartilage.
You can kind of magic if
you have a fiber compass,
for instance, most of the
stresses, if you're loading it
along the fibers, is
carried by the fibers
because they're stiffer.
So if you have like say
trabecular bone that
has varying density,
the denser bits
are going to have
higher moduli, and it's
there's going more stress
associated with that.
And so the modulus of
the trabecular bone
can affect how the loads are
distributed in the cartilage,
and that can affect the
damage in the cartilage.
And the shell, as
I mentioned before,
this sort of shell
of cortical bone
or the dense bone at the
joints can be quite thin.
It can be less
than a millimeter.
So I brought my little
bones along with me again.
So this is the head
of a femur here,
and this is a piece of a
knee joint here from a tibia.
And you can see just
looking at these
how thin the cortical shell is.
So you can get an idea
of how thin that is.
So osteoarthritis
involves a degradation
of the cartilage at the joints.
And the stress on
the cartilage is
affected by the moduli
of the underlying bone,
and the cortical shell,
the totally dense bone,
can be quite thin.
So the mechanical properties
of the trabecular bone
can affect the stress
distribution on the cartilage.
And if osteoarthritis gets
particularly bad, then
sometimes people have
joint replacements.
So when it gets really
bad, the cartilage
is degraded completely, and
the bone is rubbing on bone,
and that's quite painful.
And when it gets to that
point, people generally
have a joint replacement.
And so the way the joint
replacements are done
is say somebody who is going
to have a hip replacement, what
they do is they chop off
the top of the femur.
So they would chop the femur
off somewhere around here,
and then they have
a metal implant
that has a spherical ball.
That's like the
head of the femur.
And then it has a sort
of stem and a shaft here
that goes into the hollow
part of the long part
of the shaft of the femur.
And so they use a number of
different metals for this,
titanium and stainless
steel, and there's
a cobalt-chromium
alloy are also used.
So you need metals
that are biocompatible,
aren't going to
corrode, aren't going
to have degradation products.
And then the bone grows
around that implant,
and the bone grows in
response to mechanical loads.
So the density of
the bone depends
on the magnitude of the
load, and the orientation
of the trabeculae depends on
the orientation of the principle
stresses that are applied.
So let me write that down.
So they cut off the
end of the bone,
and they insert the implant
into the hollow shaft
of the remaining bone.
And the metals they use are
titanium, stainless steel,
and a chromium-cobalt alloy.
And then the bone grows
into that implant.
And the bone grows in
response to mechanical loads.
So the density of
the bone depends
on the magnitude
of the stresses,
and the orientation
of the bone depends
on the principle stresses.
So one of the issues that
comes up in joint replacements
is that there's a
mismatch in the moduli
between the metal and the bone.
So if you think the metal, like
something like stainless steel,
has a modulus of around
200, 210 gigapascals.
And the cortical
bone has a modulus
of about 18 gigapascals,
and the trabecular bone
has a modulus between about
0.01 and 2 gigapascals,
depending on its density.
So you're taking the bone
out, and you're replacing it
with something that's much,
much stiffer, and that
changes the stress distribution
around the remaining bone.
And one of the things
that can happen
is you can get a
loosening of the implant.
So the bone can
grow in initially,
but over time, you
get a different stress
field in the bone.
And if you have a
different stress field,
then the bone can resorb away
from the implant and cause
what's called loosening.
So if the implant
becomes loose, that's
clearly not a good thing.
It's a bad thing.
And often orthopedic
surgeons don't
like to do these joint
replacements in young people
partly because they
don't always loosen,
but occasionally they do.
And if they loosen they can
go back and do a revision.
But you can kind of
imagine after they've
chopped the head
of the femur off
and they put one
implant in, it's
not that easy to go back in and
replace that with another one.
You would need one
with a longer stem,
and the whole thing becomes a
little bit more complicated.
So this issue of
stress shielding
is what it's called
when you have
something much stiffer
that's shielding
the stresses in the bone.
The issue of stress
shielding means
that they don't like to do
the replacements on younger
patients unless you can
get stress shielding.
And if we just compare-- if we
look at the cobalt and chromium
alloy, the modulus of that
in gigapascals is about 210.
If we look at the titanium
alloys that are used,
the modulus is about 110.
If we look at the
stainless steel--
it's 316 stainless steel-- it
has a modulus of around 210.
And then if we look at the
bone, the cortical bone
has a modulus of about 18,
and the trabecular bone
has a modulus 0.01
to 2 gigapascals
depending on the density.
So after the joint
replacement happens,
the remodeling of
the bone is affected.
So the idea is that the stiffer
metal carries more of the load,
and then the bone carries less
load, and then it resorbs.
And that can lead to this
thing called loosening,
which is not desirable.
Now, this typically doesn't
happen till about 15 years
after you've had the
implant, so it's not
something that would
happen right away,
but it can happen later on.
So these are all sort
of medical reasons
why people are interested
in trabecular bone because
of osteoporosis, osteoarthritis,
and joint replacements.
So I wanted to start by
talking about the structure
of trabecular bone.
And then we'll talk about what
the stress-strain curves look
like in compression
and tension, what
are the mechanisms of
deformation and failure,
and how we can apply our models
for foams to the trabecular
bone.
So the idea is that the
structure of the bone
resembles a foam,
and here's some SCM
images of trabecular bone.
And you can see that the
bone has a varying structure.
If it's relatively
low density, this
is a bone that's almost
like an open-cell foam
if I didn't tell
you that was a bone,
you might actually think
it was an open-cell foam.
And here's a denser
piece of bone,
and you can see there's still
interconnections between all
the openings, so
it's not exactly
like a closed-cell foam,
but it's much denser,
and it's almost like
there's perforated plates
in the structure.
And then as I said the bone
can grow in response to loads.
So if you have loads that
are more or less vertical,
the trabeculae tend
to line up and be
more or less vertical with some
sort of horizontal bracing.
So this is a piece
of bone from a knee,
the condyle is sort of
towards the top of the knee.
And you can see these are sort
of plate-like pieces of bone.
They're almost parallel, and not
too surprisingly in your knee,
the loads are
typically vertical,
and then there's
a little bracing
bits that go horizontally here.
So you can get
different structures
depending on the
loading on the bone,
and the density of
the bone corresponds
to the magnitude of the
load, and the orientation
of the trabeculae corresponds
to the orientation of the load.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LORNA GIBSON: Resorb.
So when the bone density goes
down, when you lose bone mass,
that's called resorption.
So the idea is that
the trabecular bone
resembles a foam.
And in fact, the word
trabecular comes from Latin,
and in Latin, it
means little beam.
So the foams to form by bending.
They act like little beams,
and so the trabeculae
are like little
beams, even in Latin.
There's a range of
relative densities,
and you can see in
that image up there,
you can see that
there's a range.
And they range typically
between about a 5% in dense
and 50% in dense.
So something like 0.1
or 0.2 might be typical.
And the low-density bone
resembles an open-cell foam.
And the higher density,
it becomes more
like perforated plates.
And the structure can
be highly anisotropic
depending on the stress field.
And then I've got another image
here of the trabecular bone.
These images are
using what's called
micro computed tomography.
So you've probably heard
of computed tomography.
Say somebody has cancer,
they get put in a CT machine,
and they do a scan.
The micro CT is more
of a research tool.
It's the same kind
of technology,
but it's got a much
finer resolution,
and typically, you put a
small specimen into a machine
to do this.
So the specimen
might be half an inch
in diameter and an inch
tall, something like that.
So these are done by a
colleague, Ralph Muller, who's
in Zurich, and this is one of
his bread and butter things
that he has these images,
and he looks at osteoporosis.
And you can see here the
difference in the structure
for the different densities.
So here's a 26% dense piece
of bone in the femoral head.
It looks pretty sturdy
and substantial.
Here's an 11% dense piece
from the lumbar spine,
and here's a 6% dense piece.
And you can kind of see
when you go from 26 to 11,
the struts get a
little bit thinner.
And when you go from 11 to
6, the struts get very thin,
and in fact, if
they get too thin,
the struts resorb altogether,
and some of their struts
can just disappear.
So when people get
osteoporosis, what happens
is they first lose bone
mass by thinning the struts,
but then at some point, the
struts just resorb altogether.
And if you think of the struts
as a biological material,
they have bone cells in them.
So there's little osteoclasts
and osteoblasts and osteocytes
that live in the bone, the
mineral thing, the bony thing.
And those cells have dimensions
of 10s of microns, so maybe 20,
30 microns, something like that.
So the struts can't get
any thinner than that.
If they get thinner than that,
then the cells can't live,
and the thing just
disappears altogether.
And you can think of from
a mechanical point of view,
if you lose density by
thinning the struts,
you can use our sort
of foam equations.
And say the density
went from 0.2 to 0.1,
you could make some
estimate of how the modulus
and how the strength would vary
depending on our foam models.
But if you lose density
by resorbing the struts,
the struts just
disappear altogether,
then it's as if you had a
steel scaffold or a steel
structure of a building.
And now you're starting to
remove columns and remove
beams.
Yes, I know.
That's not good, not good.
And so we'll talk
a little bit more
about that when we talk
more about osteoporosis,
and you can see the
consequences of that.
But this image here
kind of gives you
a little bit of a picture of
what the bone structure looks
like as it gets less dense.
So I want to talk
a little bit more
about the bone growing
in response to load.
Let me rub off the board.
So you're probably already
a little bit familiar
with this idea.
So when astronauts
go up into space,
they often do exercises
where they have a treadmill,
and they've got springs, and
they're pulling on the springs
to try to exercise themselves.
And the reason they do
that is when they're
in microgravity, if they were
doing some kind of exercise,
they would lose bone mass.
And they will get back to Earth
where we have Earth gravity,
and they would have a problem.
So you see it in
astronauts, in microgravity.
The other place you see
this just in everyday life
is in professional
tennis players.
People have done like
x-rays of the bones
of professional tennis
players, and obviously, they
have one arm that they hit
the ball with their racquet.
The bones in that
arm actually get
bigger because they're loading
that bone over and over
again pretty much every day
when they're playing tennis,
and they're not
loading the other arm.
So their two arms are
not symmetrical because
of this loading from hitting
the racquet over and over.
And the people in 3032
have already seen this,
but I couldn't resist bringing
up the Guinea fowl experiments
again.
So obviously, you can
only do x-rays on human.
You can't sacrifice the humans
and look at their bones,
but you can with Guinea fowl.
And so people have
done experiments
where they run Guinea
fowl on treadmills,
and they have one
set of Guinea fowl
that they run on the
treadmill that's horizontal.
They have another
set of Guinea fowl
that they run on a treadmill
that's inclined to 20 degrees,
so one would think they might
have more stress on their bones
from that, and then they
have a control group
that they don't run on
the treadmill at all.
And then what they do
is they have a forced
plate on the treadmill so as
the Guinea fowl is running,
they measure the
maximum force in they're
taking high-speed video.
And then they measure
the angle of the knee
at that point at which
the force is maximum.
And they can see
there's a change
in the angle of the knee when
they put them on the inclined
treadmill, not too surprisingly.
And then these are
juvenile Guinea fowl
that haven't completely
matured their bones.
And then after about
six weeks of this,
they sacrifice the Guinea fowl,
and they do scans on the bone,
and they look at the
orientation of the bone,
and they measure what's
called the orientation
of the peak trabecular
density, which
is a way of characterizing
the orientation of the bone.
And they find that the
angle of the knee when
the Guinea fowl are running
changes by about 14 degrees.
And it turns out the
angle of the bone,
the orientation of the bone also
changes by about 14 degrees.
So the bone has remodeled
to match that change
in the forces that are applied
as the Guinea fowl are running
on a treadmill.
So this is all a
demonstration just
to show that bone grows
in response to load.
So let me write down
some of this stuff.
So I will say
astronauts-- did you
see Michael Collins is going
to come to the talk at MIT?
When I was a kid in '60s, he was
one of the Apollo astronauts.
He was like one of the
first NASA astronauts.
Anyway astronauts,
so in microgravity,
they would lose bone
if they don't exercise.
And tennis players, the
bones get larger in the arm
that they hold the racket with.
And then I'll just
write a little bit
of notes about the
Guinea fowl experiments.
So this was done by-- it's in
a paper, Ponzer et al 2006.
So they have one set
of Guinea fowl that
run on a level
treadmill, they have
another set that run on
a inclined treadmill,
and it's inclined at 20 degrees.
And then they have
a control group that
doesn't run on the treadmill.
And then they measure the
angle at the knee at the moment
of peak force on the treadmill.
And after six weeks, they
sacrificed the Guinea fowl,
and they measured
the orientation
of the peak trabecular density.
And they find that
the knee flexion
angle changed by 13.7 degrees.
And if you compared the inclined
versus the level treadmill,
and they found the orientation
of the peak trabecular
density, which they called OPDD,
also changed by 13.6 degrees.
So the idea is that the
orientation of the trabeculae
changed to match the
orientation of the loading.
Then I have a little video here.
Do you like video?
So I have a colleague who's
at Harvard who studies animal
locomotion, and they didn't
do this set of experiments,
but they do do experiments
on Guinea fowl running
on treadmills, and thought
you might find this amusing.
So let me see if I
can make this work.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Sometimes you walk
into a lab and you just
think this is what
science is all about.
-I just put the Guinea
fowl on the treadmill,
and this is something
that we commonly do.
-Welcome to the
Concord Field Station,
a defunct Nike missile base
turned scientific menagerie.
It's owned by Harvard, and
biologist Andy Biewener
is the director here.
So think of it as--
-A research lab facility for
doing comparative biomechanics
and physiology of
largely animal movement.
-And the birds are just
the tip of the iceberg.
-So do you want to see
the baby goat and the emu?
-Obviously.
-OK.
We keep it because it's
sort of like a mascot.
There used to be
a lizard colony.
You can hear the African greys.
Then the jerboas are
housed in this room here.
This is where we originally
did our pigeon flight studies.
So usually the ones with
claws and sharp teeth
and aggressive behaviors, you
want to watch out for them.
-As you might expect.
But did you know
that Guinea fowl--
-They're really
lovely to work with.
-Sometimes.
Or that--
-Rats are not very
good on treadmills.
-Yes.
That's what a rat
treadmill looks like.
And this?
-And this was
historically a treadmill
of note, the treadmill that
they first taught kangaroos
on and showed that kangaroos
stored energy in their tendons
enough that they don't actually
increase their metabolic rate
when they hop at faster speeds.
-These are the kind of
discoveries made here
with the use of high-speed
video and x-ray machines
and semi cooperative animals.
But beyond the basic
biology, Biewener
says engineers are
using this research
to build better
robots, and it can
help improve medical
treatment for people
with movement disorders.
Today the big excitement at
the lab is happening here.
Ivo Ros is studying how heart
rate changes when cockatiels
fly at different speeds.
So this is a way to look at how
much energy it takes to fly,
and that cord is
measuring heart rate.
But instead of the birds flying
faster, the wind changes speed.
-I'm going to turn it on then.
-It's hard to fly fast, and
it's hard to fly slow, Ros says.
So the expectation is
that the heart rate should
be shaped like a U.
But so far Ros is
finding that it's a flat line.
It's like the bird goes
into a stress reaction
when it takes off.
Is that just because
of the wind tunnel?
What Ros wants to know is--
- --whether or not they need to
be stressed to fly in the first
place.
-That's something that
Ros is looking into,
but today is mostly
about training.
-Keep going.
Come on.
-Imagine you're a cockatiel.
A wind tunnel is kind
of a strange experience.
-A bird in a wind tunnel
has to confront the fact
that the world is not
moving past, which
defies its normal sensory cues.
-Which pretty well sums up
the Concord Field Station
generally.
For Science Friday,
I'm Flora Lichtman.
[END PLAYBACK]
And if read The New York
Times, Flora Lichtman
used to work for NPR and would
make these Science Friday
videos for them.
But now she has a gig doing
things for The New York Times,
and she does science
videos still.
I don't know if you
quite call them videos,
but what they do is they have
these little paper puppets,
and the paper puppets
are animated and re-enact
different episodes in science.
And it's kind of amazing how
they do these little science
videos.
So if you Google
Flora Lichtman, you'll
see more Science Videos
with all sorts of things.
I guess the other
interesting anecdote
is I went to the Concord
Field Station once.
And I had done a study
on quills and animals
that have quills because the
quills have a foamy structure
in the middle.
So they're carrot,
and they have sort
of like carrot-like structures.
And they have an outer
shell that's dense,
and then they have a
foamy thing in the middle.
Anyway I did this
paper on quills
and how they work mechanically.
And Technology reviewed a
little article about it,
and they said they wanted
to take a picture of me
with a hedgehog.
The hedgehogs are little
European-- they're
like little small, cute things.
And I said, well, if
you can find a hedgehog,
I'm happy to have
my photograph taken.
And they had a hedgehog at
the Concord Field Station.
So we went out there, and we
had these big leather gloves
and took a picture.
And I don't if it was Andy
or I don't know who it was,
but I said one of
the people there,
what did you do with a hedgehog?
And he said, well, we tried
to do the treadmill study.
But hedgehogs are
like porcupines.
When they get scared, they
curl up into a little ball.
And so they said they
would put the hedgehog
down under the treadmill,
and they would start it up,
and it would make a noise,
and it would get scared it.
And it would just go into a
little ball and kind of slide
along to the end, and then it
would kind of get flopped off.
So that was the end of
the hedgehog experiments.
But they did have wallabies
there the day I went.
So they have all
sorts of animals
that they put on to treadmills,
birds that they fly,
so it's kind of
interesting to go there.
But the main idea
here is that there
was this set of experiments
with Guinea fowl that
showed just how precisely
the orientation of the bone
matches the orientation
of the loads.
AUDIENCE: Was there a difference
between the control groups?
LORNA GIBSON: Ah,
so I have slides.
I have slides.
Hang on a sec.
I got distracted by my video.
Sorry.
So here's the sort of schematic
of Guinea fowl on treadmill.
And where's the
little doo-da here?
So on the level, the
knee flexion angle
was whatever this is, 76.3,
and here was the 62.6,
so the difference is 13.7.
And then this kind of table
here summarizes these results.
So this is the maximum
trabecular density,
and this is the angle.
And here we have the incline.
Let's see, the control
was the yellow,
and the level was
the blue, and they've
got the values for that peak
trabecular density orientation.
So they've got
that for the level.
And then they looked
at the difference
between the incline and the
level in the knee angle.
That's what this thing here is.
And then between the
level and the control,
there wasn't really any
difference in the knee
angle because the control ones,
they were just walking around.
So that's the sort of slide
that has the actual data on it.
All right.
And then I showed you the video.
So we need to do a couple
more things before we
get to the modeling.
Let me get a drink.
So if we want to use
the models for foams
to try to describe
the trabecular bone,
we need to know something about
the properties of the solid.
Remember we used the properties
of the solid in the models.
So we want to get the properties
of the solid in the trabeculae,
and there's a couple of
ways you can do this.
To get the moduli, you can use
an ultrasonic wave propagation
method, and you can
measure a modulus that way.
And if they do
that, they measure
a modulus between about
15 and 18 gigapascals.
Another way to do it is
to take a piece of bone,
do a compression test on
it, measure the modulus.
Before you do the test, you
put it in the micro CT machine,
and you get a picture
of the structure,
and then you use
that as the input
to a finite element analysis.
So the finite
element analysis is
a computer numerical analysis
to do mechanical calculations.
And if you know what the
modulus of the structure is,
you can back out what
the modulus of the solid
must have been from
the fine element thing.
And those sorts of
experiments also
showed that the
modulus was around 18.
And it turns out that moduli
is about the same as cortical
bone, and the properties
of the solid trabeculae
are very similar to the
solid cortical bone.
So let me scoot over here.
So if you use an ultrasonic
wave propagation,
people have measured a modulus
for the solid in trabecular
bone of 18 gigapascals, or
you can do a finite element
calculation based on micro
CT data for the structure.
And then you measure the overall
modulus for the trabecular
bone, and then you back out
the modulus of the solid.
And people who've done
that have gotten values
of around 18 gigapascals too,
and that's very similar to what
the cortical bone is.
And so we're going to use
the following properties
for the solid in
the trabecular bone.
We're going to say
the density is 1,800
kilograms per cubic meter.
The Young's modulus
is 18 gigapascals.
The yield strength
has different values
in tension and compression.
It's about 182 megapascals
in compression.
And it's about 115
megapascals in tension.
So those are the
solid properties.
So then if we look at the
compressive stress-strain
curves, they have the shape
shown on the screen there.
And you can see how similar
the stress-strain curves
are for those for a foam.
So there's the
same three regimes
that we see for the foam.
There is a linear
elastic regime over here,
there's a stress plateau
here, and there's
some densification regime here.
These are three curves for three
different relative densities.
As the relative density goes
up, the stiffness goes up,
the plateau stress goes up,
and the densification strain
goes down.
So is the same as the foams
that we've looked at before.
And if we look at the mechanisms
of deformation and failure,
people have looked at this.
These are on a whale vertebrae.
So these are tests that are
done in a micron CT machine,
again, by Ralph Muller's group.
And here the
specimen is unloaded,
and here's the same
specimen loaded.
So you can see this platen
has come down a little bit.
And if you look at
this column here,
this trabecular here,
you can see it's bent out
and bowed out more.
And people have
found that usually
the linear elastic
behavior is controlled
by bending of that
trabeculae, and the plateau
stress is usually controlled
by some sort of buckling.
But it's not elastic buckling.
You don't recover it.
If you take a piece of
bone and you compress it,
it's going to have a
permanent deformation.
So it's inelastic buckling.
And I think we have
some more pictures.
This is another
example from whale bone
from Ralph Muller's group.
So here's the bone unloaded.
Here it's loaded to 4%
strain, here it's to 8%.
And you can start seeing
right in this area here
if you compare with up
there, it's starting to form.
And if you go up
here to 12% strain,
you see that strut right there.
That was this guy up
here, and you can see
that it's buckled right over.
So people have made measurements
like this in observations,
and you can actually
see the buckling.
And people have also done
finite element modeling.
They can take a micro
CT scan and input that
to the fine element model.
And then if they
do the compression
and they input the
properties of the solid,
they can see that they get
a buckling kind of failure.
If you have trabeculae that are
very aligned-- we have more.
Here's one more in the buckling.
So this is one of
Ralph's little movies.
So when it unloads, it
looks like it recovers,
but this is all
just an animation.
He takes several stills
and puts them together,
and it doesn't actually recover.
It's just the way that it shows.
But again, these are
two different specimens
of different densities.
You can see how
the struts deform.
They bend and then they buckle.
Let me stop there, and I'll
put some stuff on the board.
So we'll say the compressive
stress-strain curve
has the characteristic
shape of cellular solids.
And the mechanisms of
deformation and failure,
usually there is bending
followed by, usually,
inelastic or plastic buckling.
And sometimes if
the trabeculae are
aligned like that knee
that I showed you,
or if the trabecular are aligned
or if they're very dense,
then the actual
deformation is important.
And I'll just say
people have found this
by making observations using
micro computer tomography
or by finite element
calculations.
And this is a stress-strain
curve and tension
here, a tension you get
failure at small strains, then
you get micro
cracks in the bone.
And these next plots just
show some data for the bone.
So we're plotting the
Young's modulus here.
So this is a relative
Young's modulus,
the modulus of the bone
divided by the solid cell wall
material.
Here's the relative density.
Here's data for lots of
different specimens of bone.
So some of this data
is for human bones,
some is for bovine bone.
Sometimes the data
is taken where
the orientation
of the trabeculae
doesn't line up with the
direction of the loading.
So you might have trabeculae
that are oriented this way,
but you're loading it this way.
There's sometimes
different strain rates.
Let's see.
There's different groups,
and so there's a huge scatter
in the range of the data.
But you can see if
you look at it broadly
and you look at that
whole cluster of data,
the data lie close to
a line of a slope of 2.
And if you think of the
open-celled foam model
and you had bending
of the cell walls,
you'd expect that the
modulus would vary
[? to the ?] density squared.
So that's kind of the limit
of how we do the modeling.
We're really just interested in
seeing how the properties vary
with density.
If you had a particular
piece of bone,
I don't think you could use
the models to exactly predict
what the modulus of
that bone would be.
And here's the
compressive strength here.
So this is the relative
compressive strength.
Here we've normalized
it with the yield
stress of the solid bone, and
here's the relative density.
And you can see, again,
this line is of slope 2,
so that kind of speaks to the
buckling-type failure mode.
And I think I have
another one here.
This is the tensile strength.
So if you pull the
bone in tension,
you wouldn't expect
to get buckling,
you'd expect to get
plastic yielding.
And if you got yielding and you
use the open-cell foam model,
you'd expect a slope of 3/2, so
this line has a slope of 3/2.
And this line is sort of
towards the upper bound
of that set of data.
You can imagine a line that went
through it a little bit lower
but the same slope.
And so these
open-celled foam models,
they don't predict
the properties
of a particular piece
of bone because the bone
can have some anisotropy to it.
The orientation of these things
may not be perfectly lined up
with the loading.
But overall the models
give you a sense
of how the bone is
deforming and failing.
So let me write
some of this down.
So that's data for the modulus,
the compressive strength,
and the tensile strength.
And those have been
on those plots.
Those values are normalized
by data for cortical bone.
I thought somebody was talking.
It's just the chair squeaking.
And as I said the spread
in the data is large,
and that's due to anisotropy
in the bone and misalignment
between the bone orientation
and the loading direction.
So when people first started
doing tests on trabecular bone,
they typically were
orthopedics labs.
And the orthopedics labs tended
to initially cut the bone
specimens on anatomical axes.
So they would do you know
the superior-inferior,
or the medial-lateral, or
the posterior-anterior.
But the bone orientation didn't
line up with those directions.
So the bone might
have been this way,
but they were
loading it this way,
and so that gave
this misalignment.
And there could
be some variation
in the solid properties too.
So you could imagine some solid
might have more micro cracks
than another.
So if you took say human
bone of different ages,
you might expect the
older bone to have
more micro cracks in it.
So these plots put a
lot of data together,
and then the lines are based
on models for open-cell foams.
So the relative
modulus goes roughly
as a relative density squared,
and the cell walls are bending.
And the compressive
strength goes roughly
as the modulus
squared, and that's
related to this
plastic buckling.
And then the tensile
stress or tensile strength
depends on the formation
of plastic hinges,
and it goes roughly as the
density to the 3/2 power.
And one observation
that people have made
is that in compression, if the
modulus and the strength both
go as a density
squared, then the ratio
of the strength to the modulus
is just a constant, and that,
in fact, is just the
strain at failure,
or the strain for
that say, the plateau.
And that's a strain
of about 0.7%,
and that's pretty consistent
in trabecular bone.
Let's see.
And we said sometimes the
bone was relatively aligned.
So here's that
picture of the femoral
condyle again in the knee, and
you can see the bones lined up.
If you have bone that's
lined up like that
and you load it along the
direction of alignment,
then you can get axial
deformation in the trabeculae.
And then you would expect
the moduli would go linearly
with the density.
And here's some data
for the Young's modulus
and the compressive strength of
bone that was fairly aligned.
So this was selected
to be aligned.
So here's the modulus here.
And the square data points are
the longitudinal direction,
and the little diamond, these
little stars, are transverse.
So here's a line of slope
1, and again, they don't all
lie perfectly on that line, but
roughly the slope is about 1
there.
And then similarly here, this
is the compressive strength.
Now the little squares
are the longitudinal data,
and they're not exactly
on a slope of 1,
but they're more or
less on a slope of 1.
So I'll just say
in some regions,
the bone may be aligned.
And then axial
deformation is important.
And then you would expect
the modulus to go linearly
with the density
and the strength
to go linearly with the density
in the longitudinal direction.
Then finally I wanted to finish
up the bit on the modeling
by making one of these
plots a little bit
like we did for wood.
So here's the Young's
modulus of bone plotted
against the density.
The trabecular
bone is down here.
It's sort the lowest density.
And then this is
the collagen that's
in the solid part of
the bone, and this
is hydroxyapatite, the mineral.
So the modulus of hydroxyapatite
is around 120 gigapascals,
and the modulus of collagen
is somewhere around 5.
And if you make composites of
collagen and hydroxyapatite,
their moduli are going to
be in this envelope here,
and compact bone, the
modulus fits in around here.
Remember I said it was
around 18 gigapascals.
So then if you
take a compact bone
and you turn it into
trabecular bone,
you'd expect the modulus would
go down along a slope of 2.
So here's our little slope
of 2, and more or less that's
what you see with
the trabecular bone.
So the idea is that
the models give you
kind of a general idea of
how the bone is behaving,
but it's not really
meant to predict
a particular piece of bone.
Because a particular
piece is going
to have a particular geometry.
Typically they're not
equi ax and isotropic.
All right.
So are we good with
the general overview?
Are we good with how
fewer equations there
are now that we got past the
first part of the course?
So I'm going to talk a bit
more about osteoporosis,
and I'm going to talk
about some modeling
that my group did to look at the
consequences of osteoporosis.
And then later on we're
going to talk a little bit
about using metal foams as a
possible replacement material
for a trabecular bone as well.
And I have a little
bit of a talk
on using trabecular bone
in evolutionary studies
to see whether or not a species
was bipedal or quadrupedal.
So I think I talked about
this a little bit in 3032,
but I have more slides and more
stuff I'm going to talk about.
So let me get myself organized.
So osteoporosis
comes from the Latin,
and it actually
means porous bones.
So osteo means bone,
and not too surprisingly
porosis means porous.
So this next slide
gives you some idea what
osteoporotic bone looks like.
So the top slide is normal
bone in a 55-year-old woman.
These are sections
from the lumbar spine.
And that bone up
here is 17% dense,
so the relative
density is point 0.17.
And this is a section
from the same area
of bone in an 86-year-old
woman, and it's 7% dense.
So you can see there's a huge
difference in the density,
and you can start
to see what happens
when you lose bone mass.
So if you look at this bone up
here, it's all well connected.
Each little trabeculae
is connected
to its neighboring friends.
And you can see down here,
I mean, you look at this
and you kind of go ouch
just looking at it.
Because this piece of bone here
is just kind of dangling off,
not connected to anything.
And you can see the struts
have gotten thinner,
so they've lost bone
mass by thinning.
And then as I said
when the thickness gets
less than they are roughly
equal to the size of the cells,
then the cells
can't live anymore,
and the bone strut just
disappears altogether.
So it's not too surprising
that if you lose this much bone
mass, there's
mechanical consequences,
and there's a greater
risk of fracture.
And as I said the two most
common types of fractures
are hip fractures and
vertebral fractures.
So let's see here.
So as people age,
everybody loses bone mass.
And happily for you and
not so happily for me,
the bone mass peaks
at about 25 years old.
So you're probably
either not at the peak
or just barely at the peak.
And then it decreases
after that every year.
I'm considerably older than you.
And in women, when you
go through menopause,
the cessation of
estrogen production
increases the bone loss.
And so typically,
osteoporosis is most common
in post menopausal women.
And osteoporosis is
defined as a bone mass 2.5
standard deviations
or more below that
of a young, normal mean.
So it's not like you
fall and break your hip
and they say you
have osteoporosis.
It's based on the bone mass.
And as I said, the
trabeculae thin and then
they resorb completely.
So anybody here take Latin?
Yes.
I did Latin for one
year in high school.
So trabeculae, with
an E on the end here,
trabeculae, I suppose,
is the plural.
Trabecula with an A is singular.
And that comes from Latin.
So you don't say trabeculas.
That's a no-no.
All right.
Let me get rid of these.
So if we saw that the
strength of the bone
varies as the
density squared, you
can begin to see how sensitive
the strength is going
to be to this bone mass loss.
So say you went from a density
of 0.2 to a density of 0.1,
then the densities
changed by a factor of 2
so that the densities
gone down by 1/2,
but the strength is going
to go down by a factor of 4.
You're going to have the
strength to be a 1/4.
And so you're going to have
a big change in the strength.
And you can imagine is
the trabeculae thins,
this buckling gets
easier to happen.
And then once the
trabeculae begin
to resorb as they disappear
altogether, it's like I said.
it's like having a
building's framework.
Now, you're removing
beams and columns,
and the strength is going to
go down even more dramatically.
And the way we model
the osteoporotic bone
is we use finite
element analysis.
So before we talked
about using the unit cell
for the honeycomb.
But to use the
unit cell, you have
to have repeating unit
cells, and obviously, you
don't have that.
You've got local variations in
what the structure looks like.
And we also used a
dimensional analysis.
And the dimensional
analysis relies
on the geometry being similar
from one specimen to another,
and you can't
really rely on that
either for the
osteoporotic bone.
And so what we've
done is-- and this
is what other people do as well,
is use finite element modeling
to represent the bone.
So initially what we did was
we used a 2D Voronoi model.
So remember we talked about
Voronoi honeycombs and Voronoi
foams.
So I like to start out
with simple things,
so we started out with 2D
Voronoi model for a honeycomb.
Then we did a 2D representation
of vertebral bone.
And then we had a 3D Voronoi.
And I had a couple of
students who did this.
Matt Silver was the one
who did the first two,
and Sereca Vagilla was the
one who did the last one.
So let's see.
I think that's probably a good
place to stop there for today.
So next time I'll talk about the
modeling of osteoporotic bone,
and we might talk a little
bit about metal bones
as a substitute for trabecular--
metal foams as a substitute.
I don't think we'll get
to the evolution stuff.
We probably won't
quite finish next time.